look women don't live single-issue lives
um and I think it's really important for
both men and women to be able to walk
about their lives and expect their
public services and institutions to
recognize them as men and women and that
Foster caring um and adoption uh
services and all of those other services
are not co-opted by what I think is a
quasi religious pernicious Cult of
transgenderism and just and and lies and
and like I said there's other lies that
stem from that so whilst it may be
single issue I mean the brexit party may
have been accused of being single issue
and I believe we are now no longer in
Europe so I think the power of single
issue is is perhaps something that we
need in in this country at the moment so
that people can really kind of stake
stake their claim to a particular
principle and that's something that I
think we stand for at the party of women
or we will stand for once we're
registered